we got something else coming up here a  prominent CEO making a significant gift  the battle the pandemic that sounds like  good news is some good news Twitter and  square CEO Jack Dorsey is donating 1  billion dollars to fight coronavirus  relief efforts that's 28 percent 28  percent of his total wealth Dorsey said  he'll donate the stock that he owns in  square the money will be distributed  through a private company he created  called start small Dorsey says once the  pandemic is over the cash will go to  relief programs like girls health  education and universal basic income  Gail Silicon Valley really stepping out  nothing small about what he's doing  though